au second tour a obtenu à l'unanimité le
prix goncourt 1970 michel tournier pour
le roi des zones
voilà monsieur maintenant la parole oui
comprend des membres du compte les
pistes mais battu we know sartoux a
décidé d'accorder le prix goncourt des
capteurs et c'est loin de ce tumulte
dans le cadre d'un petit village de
l'île de france que jean princeteau a
rencontré le nouveau lorient choisel
quelques kilomètres de chevreuse un
petit village à l'orée du bois avec son
monument aux morts sa mairie son église
paris n'est pas loin et choisel à
quelques habitants illustre ingrid
bergman claude ce pacte et et michel
tournier qui écrit dans la solitude d'un
vieux presbytère au milieu des arbres
pouillé par le top vous vivez ici dans
une très grande solitude est ce que
c'est une volonté simplement de travail
d'un écrivain travailler à l'aise
ou bien est-ce que c'est un peu autre
chose aussi mais je pourrais vous dire
que tout en paradoxe c'est presque par
goût de la société parce que dans une
grande ville
on vit dans la foule avec laquelle on a
vraiment aucun rappeur j'ai vécu des
années dans un immeuble à paris sans
connaître le nom des autres locataires
je ne les connaissais que par les bruits
qui faisait qu'il dérangeait tandis que
dans un paysage
rural à la campagne on a des relations
normales avec les voisins on les voit on
parle avec eux on connaît leur histoire
au jour le jour ne spoile une petite
chronique le bouche à oreille qui se
fait et qui est humaine
je crois vraiment que la vraie solitude
vous savez je crois qu'on la porte en
soi et je crois qu'un un père de famille
nombreuse directeur d'une entreprise
avec de nombreux ouvriers peut très bien
avoir en lui une solitude dévastatrice
n'êtes pas du navet solitaire non plus
parce que vous avez un collaborateur
ah oui j'ai mon filleul le rang qui vit
en partie avec moi en partie dans sa
famille qui m'accompagne qui va en
vacances avec moi et je lui raconte mes
histoires je les ai c'est un petit peu
sur lui c'est un garçon de 12 ans et est
ce qu'il n'est pas un petit peu terrifié
et de venir chez un homme parce que vous
êtes un homme alors oui mais vous savez
les hommes les enfants les enfants
aiment les ogres n'oubliez pas que
perreault a écrit ces histoires pour les
enfants et qu' il aime ça se passait il
ya un côté l'image d'épinal dans l'ogre
qui est extrêmement séduisant pour les
enfants ça n'est pas du tout
incompatible